(Big band music)
- I think it's funny that
guys are never called crazy.
Cause I feel like guys do
things that are like, crazy.
But guys are never called crazy.
For a guy to get called
crazy he's gotta be
like naked in an alley,
jerking off on a dead pigeon.
(Audience laughter)
Singing bible hymns.
♪ Over the river ♪
But even then we're like,
"Oh my God that guy is
homeless that is so sad.
(Sigh)
Do you have a dollar,
give him a dollar."
But for a girl to
get called crazy
we just have to send you
two text messages in a row.
"She's fucking crazy man.
She's fucking stalking me, bro
she's obsessed with me man."
Like, I don't
know, I'm not crazy
I'm just locked
out of the house.
Can you let me in the house?
I'm not stalking
you, I live here.
My house til we live together.
I'm not obsessed
with you, I hate you.
Guys are never called crazy.
But I feel like guys do things
that are actually crazy.
Like things that would put
you in an insane asylum.
Like you guys will talk
to athletes, in the tv.
And you think they
can fuckin' hear you.
That's literal schizophrenia
that is a mental illness.
Like I was watchin'
some of my guy friends
a couple months ago they're
watching a Giants game
and they were talking
to Eli Manning.
Having a conversation
with this person.
They were like, "Eli listen
to me, Eli listen to me,
we have been through this bro."
I'm like bitch you have not
been through shit with him man.
He cannot hear you.
And even if he could hear you,
why would he take
advice from you?
You can't even
get your Heinekens
in the fuckin' garbage can.
I feel like you
guys watching sports
should give you a little
more sympathy for us.
Cause now you know what
it's like to yell at a man
and have him
completely ignore you.
(Audience laughter)
Everyday is Sunday for us.
You guys say the meanest
things to these athletes,
the meanest things.
Like they're watching Tom
Brady and they were like,
"Tom Brady you suck."
"Tom Brady sucks."
I don't know that
much about football,
but I'm pretty sure Tom Brady
doesn't suck at football.
I'm pretty sure you suck.
I'm pretty sure all
you suck at football.
I just wish these athletes
would stand up for themselves
you know, against these
horrible things you say.
I wish just one time Tom
Brady would look directly into
the camera and be like, "Hey
man, fuck you, I got this.
I make 20 million dollars a year
and you can't even
do a fuckin' sit up.
Get off my dick, man."
(Big Band music)